non
10e anniversaire du centre georges
pompidou dans le quartier beaubourg à
paris
10 ans de succès que nous fêterons ici
en direct dans cette élection de 20
heures deuxième type de l'actualité la
convention nationale de l'idf tout le
monde en parle mais on pense beaucoup
aux élections présidentielles mais
personne ne le dit yves allégret est
mort le cinéaste est âgé de 79 ans lui
doit notamment les orgueilleux et
d'aider l'envers et puis aujourd'hui
samedi 31 janvier 1987 nouvelle journée
de détention pour les otages français au
liban marcel fontaine et marcel carton
jean paul kauffmann jean louis normandin
d'antenne 2 n'ont toujours pas été
libérés
bonsoir nous sommes en direct du sortent
du centre georges pompidou dans le
quartier beaubourg dans quelques minutes
quelques secondes car le cortège
officiel arrive le président de la
république françois mitterrand va
appuyer sur un bouton vous allez le voir
et je vais demander aux caméras d'un de
se tourner tout à fait doucement vers le
lieu où va se passer une horloge magique
une horloge à remonter le temps va être
va être déclenchée
cette horloge va ainsi seconde par
seconde permettre de comptabiliser le
temps qui nous sépare de l'an 2000 à
côté du président de la république et
sur un fond de musique de percussions le
petit pierre louison il aura 20 ans en
l'an 2000 le président la république l'a
embrassée pierre louise on s'approche
avec lui de ce bouton de ce bouton rouge
et regardez bien l'horloge cela va
déclencher un système tout à fait
sophistiqué qui permettra de savoir à
combien de secondes
nous en sommes de l'an 2000 instant
émouvant car il s'agit de déclencher un
temps un temps le président a imposé son
doigt le petit garçon est appuyé et
voilà normalement d'un va se déclencher
biabiany s'est choisi dernier type app
d'angoise a déclenché le temps comme ça
parce que l'on domine toujours
je crois qu'il est très important nous
fêtons actuellement le dixième
anniversaire de momo du centre pompidou
je pense qu'il est très important pour
tous les français et particulièrement
pour des jeunes comme celui ci qui aura
airs et 20 ans à l'an 2000 de connaître
d'approché de connaître les merveilles
et esthétiques et techniques de notre
siècle 20e pour aborder le prochain avec
la volonté de l'effort et j'espère la
volonté de créer c'est la signification
voyez sujet d'itron passé la technique
maintenant le centre pour vous ce sont
les arts je crois que le panorama est
complet merci monsieur le président vous
retrouve dans quelques minutes dans ce
journal d'antenne 2 remercie
effectivement claude sérillon a tout de
suite nous vous retrouvons donc au
centre pompidou dans quelques minutes
mais d'abord le reste de l'actualité
avec la politique avec la prudence de
l'udf
c'était la convention nationale
aujourd'hui à paris si tout le monde
pensait aux présidentielles de 88
personne n'a voulu choisir un candidat
d'abord un projet ensuite un candidat
comme a dit jean le calvez pour le reste
on retiendra fait de réaffirmation union
de la majorité et soutien au
gouvernement
olivier werner l'udf au zénith pour se
mesurer un congrès puisqu'une convention
un rassemblement plus qu'un spectacle
mais les clins d'oeil n'ont pas manqué
en scène on se marie on divorce on sait
la gueule on revient on se lance des
petites flèches haut à droite à gauche
qui finalement tout ça s'arrange on se
retrouve comme une bonne plus de joie
qui est bien avec tout le monde
soul elle de monsieur le cas du quai la
carence poule membre observateur détendu
mais attentif
jacques toubon seul représentant rpr
invité ce matin jean le camus et citait
raymond barre le grand absent du zénith
en fin de matinée valéry giscard
d'estaing cité quant à lui jean lecanu
et échanges de politesses volonté
certaine en tout cas de resserrer les
rangs lorsque la politique française
or a été débarrassée de l'union de la
gauche alors sur les ruines du programme
commun nous pourrons enfin renouer le
dialogue entre tous les français qui
n'ont pas l'esprit imprégné par
l'idéologie marxiste
nous pourrons enfin les réconcilier
après la désillusion surgir à
l'espérance en vedette américaine
françois léotard un discours musclé et
un avertissement échouera si le
gouvernement
à l'applaudimètre avec l'avantagé d'être
à la tribune françois léotard rivalisera
avec raymond barre tout le monde aura
tenu promesse
sauf jean lecanuet les présidentielles
il n'a pu s'empêcher d'en parler mais
pas le moindre n'ont pas le moindre
prénom et pour que la majorité
l'emportent que faut-il deux candidats
et deux seulement l'un soutenu par l'udf
et l'autre par le rpr poussons plus
avant notre réflexion pour que la
victoire soit assuré au second tour
au second tour le report des suffrages
udf rpr devrait total un plus un égale 2
ce sera barre
léotard ou alors il sort marseillaise au
parti socialiste la fédération des
bouches-du-rhône détient un record celui
du nombre d'adhésions en une seule année
une progression fulgurante de 12 à 18
milles en un an
étrange tellement étrange que les
responsables nationaux s'en sont
inquiétées n'y aurait-il pas quelques
fausses cartes là dessous et le ps
d'envoyer ses meilleurs limiers et non
des moindres sur place reportage
dominique laurie robert rosier marcel
debarge numéro trois du ps qui jouent
dans cette affaire l'incorruptible aura
bien des difficultés pour démêler le
vrai du faux
découvrir par quel miracle les effectifs
socialistes ont fait un bond de 76% en
un an sur le vieux port
nouvel épisode sans doute de la lutte
d'influencé entre les héritiers de
gaston defferre regroupés autour de
philippe san marco et les amis le michel
pezet mais ici on levitte de dramatiser
pour les militants des bouches du rhône
ce sont les parisiens qui font tout un
pastis uniquement parce que c'est
marseille
douze ont généreusement distribués par
certains des buts c'est une pratique qui
existait depuis longtemps mais que
personne n'aurait trouvé dans tous les
partis n ya pas que le parti socialiste
et pourrait voir un petit peu à droite
ce qui se passe à oreille se font pas de
cadeaux commandés à marseille plus
sérieux
bernard pigamo secrétaire fédéral aux
sections ne cache pas que certains se
sont livrés à des indélicatesses et il a
des preuves
regardez une centaine de lettres de
protestation de marseillais affirmant
avoir été enrôlé à leur insu on parti
socialiste est dans les couloirs de la
fédération
les amis de gaston defferre font figure
d'accusée à la mairie philippe san marco
s'en défend il ya plein d'accusations
elles sont toutes anonyme et je mets au
défi qui que ce soit de prouver quoi que
ce soit alors qu'on sorte qu'on se taise
sur ce niveau là il a d'ailleurs remis
un document hier à la commission de
contrôle document qui conteste la
validité du fichier de la fédération des
propos évidemment contestée par michel
pezet là on vit la situation nous paraît
beaucoup plus clair moi je suis heureux
d'être encore une fois on plus bien
vérifier que ces dix huit mille enlevé
il sentait bien que ces dix-huit mille
non il existe ce sont des femmes et des
hommes qui participent à la vie
politique après avoir entendu les
responsables des deux camps la
commission devra répercuter les points
de vue et les accusations au bureau
exécutif à paris les solutions sont en
cours sans aucun problème une chose est
sûre marcel debarge est bien décidé à
remettre de l'ordre
certaines pratiques sont inadmissibles
at il déclaré les bouches du rhône doit
fonctionner comme l'ensemble des
fédérations
marseille n'est pas une exception
verdict mercredi prochain l'électricité
moins chère dès demain les tarifs d'edf
edf pa rle en baisse de 1% en moyenne à
la demande des pouvoirs publics
cette baisse est la troisième en un an
elle va plus profiter aux industriels
qu'aux particuliers à hold up dans un
magasin leclerc à champigny sur marne un
mort et trois blessés graves c'est un
convoyeur de fonds qui a été tué les
malfaiteurs ont réussi à prendre la
fuite
une bombe dans une voiture à marseille
il ne s'agissait pas d'un attentat
vraisemblablement des gangsters qui se
promenait avec des explosifs
ils sont morts tous les deux roland
sicard pris à leur propre piège c'est
sans doute en manipulant leurs bombes
que les deux hommes se sont tués ce
matin 9 heures 45 dans le quartier de la
millière à marseille
deux voitures sont en stationnement
devant cette école lorsque l'explosion
se produit il ya une formidable
déflagration toutes les vitres ont volé
en éclats la porte de les portes à des
classes en se sont ouvertes dans les
serrures en sauter aucun blessé parmi
les élèves de l'école mais les deux
occupants de la voiture ont été tués sur
le coup dans la matinée l'hypothèse d'un
attentat à la voiture piégée avait été
avancé une piste que les enquêteurs
semblent ce soir écartée il s'agirait en
fait de deux truands qui auraient été
victimes de leurs propres bombes en
préparant un braquage à l'explosif les
otages français de somalie le dénouement
est proche les dix membres de médecins
sans frontières vont être libérés c'est
confirmé il ya quelques difficultés de
dernière minute le quai d'orsay pensent
que leur libération aura lieu dans deux
ou trois jours au liban toujours
l'incertitude sur le sort de terre et
wet le médiateur dans la sphère des
otages occidentaux il n'a toujours pas
réapparu
certains le disent en résidence
surveillée d'autres affirme qu'il
poursuit sa médiation
mais l'archevêque de canterbury dont il
est l'envoyé spécial a exprimé son
inquiétude
les philippines fait lundi qu'a lieu le
référendum constitutionnel en fait il
s'agira d'un plébiscite pour ou contre
la présidente cory aquino
le scrutin aura lieu alors qu'il y ait
encore des soubresauts après la
rébellion de la semaine dernière après
aussi que les meneurs étaient arrêtés
reportage
martine laroche joubert et jean françois
renaud pour soutenir cory aquino et la
porter vers la victoire
ils sont plus de 200 mille ici cet après
midi moins nombreux que l'année dernière
au moment les élections mais toujours
aussi ferme ans
correia kino sa robe jaune couleur de
chance une apparente sérénité malgré les
drames et les coups de force des
derniers jours un discours énergique
d'une même voix unie je ne suis ni à
droite ni à gauche mais avec le peuple
l'armée sera purgée des incidents comme
celui de la prise de la chaîne cette les
terminer c'est surprenant dans ses
discours c'est l'absence de toute
allusion aux massacres de magnola ce
massacre où l'armée la semaine dernière
à tirer sur des paysans les paysans
c'est une bonne partie de l'électorat de
correia qui n'en est ce massacre même si
elle n'est pas directement responsable
l'a déjà fait perdre de sa popularité
province de tarlac au nord de manille
ici a grandi correia qui nos oignons
terre aujourd'hui anne a connu un de ces
inconnus tu as mendiola leopoldo alonso
33 ans deux enfants
étrange coïncidence lait opl de alonso
et des travailleurs agricoles sur la
propriété même de cory aquino l'hacienda
luigi temps pour 30 francs par jour ils
étaient une vingtaine qui la semaine
dernière avaient quitté leur village
pour manifester à manille militants du
rrq amps mouvements d'extrême gauche des
paysans philippins ils réclament une
réforme agraire une réforme qui n'en
finit pas d'être promise et reportée
cory aquino elle même n'a jamais
distribué les terres qu'elles possèdent
et cela malgré ses engagements
c'est donc la déception d'autant plus
violente que l'espoir était fort votre
mari avait t-il votée l'année dernière
pour marcos ou pour cory aquino
son mari avait voté pour correa qui nous
nous voulons lui donner une petite
chance par rapport au régime de marcos
ce régime est un peu plus souple plus
attentifs ou pour rejoindre le précédent
nous voulons lui donner sa chance
l'après midi
du désespoir à la fuite vers la guérilla
communiste
le pas est vite franchi si qu'aurillac
in ovo gagner il lui faut agir vite
voilà il est temps maintenant de
retrouver claude sérillon qui ôte au
centre pompidou avec le président
mitterrand et le premier ministre
jacques chirac claude c'est cela oui
presque presque hervé tout ça se fait
bien sûr dans une une certaine cohésion
mais en même temps un petit peu
d'inattendu puisque le président est en
train de visiter le début de des
différentes expositions de ce centre
georges pompidou alors je vais en
profiter pour pour saluer la réussite de
ces dix années de succès du centre
georges pompidou 76 millions d'entrées
en disant quelque chose comme 24 mille
visiteurs par jour c'est beaucoup plus
que la tour eiffel c'est pratiquement
l'équivalent de disneyland vous rendez
compte de l'événement
c'est donc un événement dix ans après
parce que rappelez vous lorsque le genre
le président de la république valéry
giscard d'estaing le 31 janvier 1977 a
inauguré le centre georges pompidou on
parlait beaucoup plus de ferraille de
mots peu agréables à propos de cette
grande carcasse il y avait vraiment
beaucoup de sceptiques
et puis le succès est venu six est venue
d'abord par l'organisation ça soit de
l'ircam de la bibliothèque et de toutes
les activités qui sont proposées ici les
visiteurs se pressent énormément il y a
beaucoup de jeunes et sur 100 personnes
une sur deux va la bibliothèque c'est
vous dire l'intérêt de ce centre georges
pompidou dans le quartier beaubourg
actuellement le président de la
république qui est accompagné de madame
georges pompidou du premier ministre
jacques chirac de monsieur balladur reçu
balladur qui a joué un rôle très
important à un moment où on disait oh ça
coûtera cher
mais ce qui l'est bien utile de
continuer l'activité monsieur balladur
était à la tête d' amis du centre
georges pompidou et il s'est battu pour
qu'on continue à l'entretenir qu'on
continue à donner des subventions pour
cent ça coûte effectivement assez cher
le centre coûte un million de francs par
jour sont des chiffres fournis dans un
dossier très explicite publié par notre
confrère l'express
aujourd'hui alors dans quelques instants
le président de la république va se
trouver devant une maquette du centre
c'est une maquette reconstitué avec le
travail fait par renzo piano qui était
un italien il richard rodgers qui est un
américain piano et rodgers avait imaginé
départ/arrivée pippen qui se
superposaient ce qui permettait
d'ailleurs
formellement de perdre absolument aucune
place car tous les services je dirais
tous les services et être à l'extérieur
pardonnez moi de jeter temps en temps un
petit coup d'oeil sur sur ma gauche
c'est parce que le président de la
république et a condamné également du
directeur de centre monsieur pierre
maheu est en train d'effectuer une
visite alors je pense que je vais
pouvoir demander au président de la
république et un ici plutôt parler merci
beaucoup
bonsoir monsieur le président nous on
est rejoint par madame georges pompidou
bonsoir madame bonsoir monsieur le
premier ministre
ce président j'évoquais devant des
spectateurs fait qu'il y a dix ans
beaucoup de gens parlaient de la
carcasse pompidou alors est-ce que la
première vous l'avez vu vous avez une
réaction de fascination ou de rejet
d'acceptation et j'apporte la preuve et
j'ai dû défendre ce projet et j'ai écrit
à l'époque des articles polémiques pour
estimer qu'on commet une erreur en
refusant ce bâtiment audacieux dans ce
quartier inscrit lundi soir et que cette
sorte d'antinomie pouvait être
profitable à l'esthétique de la ville
on vous attribue plutôt des goûts
classiques que dégoût moderne
j'ai peut être vrai en l'occurrence
lorsque j'ai été consultés lorsque j'ai
assisté à cette bataille esthétique
j'étais dans le camp de ceux qui étaient
pour est il important pour un chef
d'état de laisser une grande oeuvre
d'art comme le président pompidou a
laissé ici on a toujours envie d'autre
part
un chef d'état dispose du temps que n'a
pas un gouvernement poursuivre à travers
les années quatre ans 5 ans 10 ans se
tend une oeuvre qui doit s'inscrire dans
le paysage français
c'est le cas du centre pompidou ça fait
un tout avec le musée d'orsay l'archipel
la pyramide paye quand on pensait au
louvre au relecq assure le musée d'orsay
au relecq assure aujourd'hui le centre
pompidou aux perspectives qui s'ouvrent
sur le xxème siècle oui c'est une
continuité du contenu haute conception
de l'art de la technique à travers les
siècles
il faut les magnifier mais pas seulement
regarder vers le passé
il faut 1 relié se passer à l'avenir
qu'il s'agit de construire
merci monsieur le président madame
pompidou je crois que votre mari de
président pompidou avait dit ça va faire
crier win avait dit ça va faire crier et
sert à s'écrier d'ailleurs fait beaucoup
crié
est ce que maintenant vous juger ça un
petit peu avec le sourire ou est ce que
vous retenez comme ceux qu'on était un
peu dur
non je retiens plus rien parce que comme
c'est un succès qui attendent personnes
qui viennent là tous les jours puisque
c'est la réalisation de son rêve de ce
qu'il avait pensé alors par conséquent
je n'ai aucun regret non les activités
du centre pompidou elles sont très
diverses est ce qu'il y en a une qui
vous tient particulièrement à coeur
je veux pas dire vraiment qu'il y en ait
une parce que je suis très intéressé par
la peinture mais aussi par la musique
donc l'ircam le musée puis toutes les
autres activités sont intéressantes
il faudrait beaucoup plus de temps pour
tout voir en l'ircam c'est de la musique
et beaucoup de recherche en musique vous
êtes passionné par ce domaine oui je
suis assez passionné par la recherche et
la musique contemporaine d'abord parce
que je suis très ami de pierre boulez
est magnifié et
une fois qu'on était dit si on est un
petit peu drogue c'est merci madame
pompidou mais se prémunissent bonsoir
vous êtes un mère comblée vous avez des
monuments vous venez d'inaugurer le
musée d'orsay au final président de la
république récemment vous le trouver au
centre pompidou au centre pompidou est
ce qu'il y a chez vous un choix plus
particulier dans cet ensemble
il ne faut pas mélanger les genres
le centre georges pompidou est une chose
tout à fait tout à fait exceptionnel qui
restera dans l'histoire qui a donné à la
france
quelque chose qu'elle n'avait pas et
dont elle était dit qui est enviée et
imité un peu partout à l'étranger
maintenant par les plus grandes nations
et qui a été voulu par le président
georges pompidou qui inscrit ainsi son
nom dans la très courte liste des hommes
qui sur le plan culturel rond marqué à
la fois leur pays et le monde alors je
suis effectivement comblé d'être merde
de la ville où il ya le centre où on
sait que vous êtes très lié par le
souvenir à monsieur pompidou est ce que
le fait d'avoir créé ce centre a été une
chose très importante dans sa carrière
dans son environnement de sa présidence
sa défense n'a pas fini de découvrir
tout ce qu'elle doit à georges pompidou
qui était un homme de sagesse et de
culture
qu'ils étaient capables des choses les
plus audacieuses et il l'a prouvé en lui
donnant une industrie moderne et en lui
donnant le centre georges pompidou
tout en conservant le respect de nos
traditions parce qu'il était très
profondément attachés à notre histoire
et c'est vrai que j'ai été dès le début
associés à cette grande aventure qu'en
1974 après son décès hélas j'ai fait
partie j'étais premier ministre de ce
qui contre vents et marées et contre les
cris que vous évoquez tout à l'heure ils
ont été nombreux et les sarcasmes ont
imposé la réalisation du projet qu'il
avait voulu et qui sont évidemment la
fois ému aussi heureux de voir le grand
succès qui est universellement reconnue
aujourd'hui à l'égard du ce dans une
émission sur une chaîne concurrente
j'avais entendu votre choix pour de la
musique moderne vous êtes définitivement
pour l'art moderne pas pour l'art
moderne je suis pour la fac et les
bonnes qualités qu'il soit classique
moderne étrangers français toutes les
civilisations sont exprimés
quant à musique moderne cette fois aussi
un accès facile et je suis un peu comme
madame pompidou j'ai été pour beaucoup
pini sied dans ce domaine par pierre
boulez merci monsieur le premier
ministre
voilà pour ces trois interviews que nous
avons pu réaliser en direct dans ce
journal
je vous propose maintenant de voir avec
sylvie marion le reportage qui a pu
tourner sur l'exposition que le
président de la république madame
pompidou et jacques chirac vont aller
visiter c'est le visiteur et son double
c'est juste derrière moi vous allez le
découvrir
c'est une manière de regarder comment
les visiteurs viennent ici dans ce
centre georges pompidou
tout le monde connaît le bâtiment
beaubourg et nous y sommes presque tous
aller au moins une fois les au coeur du
bâtiment
derrière ces espaces réservés au public
les bureaux administratifs et capi dans
un coin le sociologue de beaubourg cela
fait six ans qu'il nous et tu dis vous
et moi nous les usagers du centre
pompidou dix études de sociologie à
envoyer d'ici là la dernière sur le
centre pompidou depuis depuis cinq ou
six ans mais à quoi sociologue à
beaubourg ça fait quoi
ça fait quoi écouter à beaubourg les
gens regardent quoi les gens regardent
les oeuvres les gens regardent la
bibliothèque
les gens regardent le paysage et le
sociologue regarde les gens sont terrain
d'étude privilégié la bpi la
bibliothèque publique d'information le
lieu le plus fréquenté de beaubourg
douze mille personnes par jour soit la
moitié des entrées du centre
c'est la seule bibliothèque de france où
tous les livres sont visibles
disponibles comme chez soi mais on n'est
pas chez soi alors dit le sociologue
beaubourg lieux publics où le
transformant symboliquement en lieux
privés
la majorité des lecteurs lisent assia
une tarder c'est comme ça qu'ils font à
la maison mais ce sont ceux qui prennent
une posture bizarre qui forge le plus
l'image si particulière de la bpi même
lorsqu'il ya des places libres
regardez comment ils font celui ci doit
aimer la solitude alors il dresse une
barrière symbolique entre lui et nous
celle là ne se rend même pas compte
qu'elle n'est pas d'acide dans son
jardin quant à lui il lui faut un petit
repos comme à la maison entre deux
textes ici dans la mesure où il ya un
monde fou
vous n'êtes plus sous le regard de
personnes et chacun peut importer dans
le centre pompidou ses habitudes qu'il à
l'extérieur ses habitudes que deux
postures ses habitudes de paroles ses
habitudes d'errance d'itinéraires de
cheminement sans que ça ne gêne
absolument et sans qu'il soit rappelé à
l'ordre après avoir pris possession des
lieux on tente de posséder les livres la
photocopie pour rapporter chez soi
quelques pages de bouquins c'est
classique mais la sono skopies vous
connaissiez une nouvelle manière de
s'approprier minutes près si ce marché
constitué non seulement deux des points
de vie semée de tout engagement à court
terme pratiques et les planques tous les
soirs les bibliothécaires retrouve des
volumes qu'un lecteur qui se croient
rusé à cacher dans une cote qui n'est
pas la sienne
il fuit à côté d'un livre sur le langage
informatique pascal les pensée du
philosophe une vraie joie pour le
sociologue
et vous voulez mais votre bibliothèque
écoutez oui je reste tout à fait fasciné
par ce qui se passe au sein de vidéos et
d'insalubrité que j'arrive pas encore à
me lasser avoir l'impression que j'ai
déjà vu ce que je suis en train de voir
et surtout la prochaine fois que vous
irez à la bibliothèque de boudou si vous
rencontrez le sociologue étudiés voilà
j'espère nous allons retrouver claude
sérillon dans quelques minutes au centre
pompidou il est dans la cohue de cette
visite du président mitterrand et du
premier ministre jacques chirac un site
madame claude pompidou
pour l'instant le reste de l'actualité
avec d'abord une triste nouvelle
le cinéma est en deuil il valait gray
est mort il avait 79 ans était l'un des
plus grands réalisateurs français de
l'après-guerre avec son frère marc
réalisateur lui aussi avec carnet becker
ou encore noir il valait graisser
l'auteur de dédée d'anvers ou des
orgueilleux sylvie marion oui il va les
grès est l'un des grands réalisateurs
qui a contribué à forger l'image du
cinéma réaliste français de
l'après-guerre avec des films noirs
désespérés comme des l'élan vers une si
jolie petite plage manège sa vedette
préférée simone signoret qu'il épouse en
1950 et dont il a une fille catherine
allégret les voici le jour des obsèques
de simone il y a deux ans son plus grand
succès les orgueilleux en 53 scénario de
jean paul sartre vedette gérard philippe
et michel manquant est un metteur en
scène
très agréable un peu gouailleur un peu
sarcastique comme ça mais probablement
avec un fond de grande pudeur
il était d'une famille protestante et il
montrait jamais ses sentiments ce qu'il
avait dans son coeur mais je suis
certaine que et il était un homme très
très tendre au fond le sport maintenant
avec le ski chez les suisses font sauter
la banque ou champion du monde à crans
montana crans montana pardon il faut
dire qu'ils sont chez eux en suisse dans
la descente hommes ils étaient cinq au
départ ils ont terminé tous les cinq
dans les six premiers cp terreau muller
qui gagne patrick chêne un suisse
vainqueur de la descente du championnat
du monde ce n'est pas une surprise le
succès devait terme eu l'air devant
firma zurbriggen est un peu inattendu
pourtant le très puissant muller a donc
su mieux que son compatriote négocier la
succession de sault imposé aux
concurrents il fallait des jambes de la
fameuse glisse mais aussi un bon
tempérament pour mériter le titre
aujourd'hui
notons aussi que verneret le français
onzième de l'épreuve à chausser des skis
autrichien
une grande première pour l'équipe de
france généralement liés aux poules des
fabricants mais propre et 11e verneret
mais c'est péter müller qui l'emportent
devant zurbriggen
vivement patrick chêne en parlait à
propos des français ce petit scandale
verneret qui 11e donc à skis avec des
skis autrichien en voile mauvais début
pour les australiens dans la finale de
l'america cup c'est le bateau américain
stars and stripes qui a gagné la
première régate face à coup cabourg à 3
l'australien assez facilement
c'est la victoire de stars and stripes
près de deux minutes d'avancé
le premier qu'il ya une 4 égal je vous
le rappelle remporte cette coupe de
l'america en boxe et la dernière chance
mondiale pour monteiro ce soir à
montpellier il va rencontrer le mexicain
romane alors on va les voir je pense à
la pesée j'espère en tout cas voilà les
deux boxeurs l'un après l'autre on va
les voir à la pesée et puis sachez tout
de même que retransmission du match ce
soir sur antenne 2 donc rester fidèle à
antenne 2 vous verrez ce match de boxe
après le dernier journal voilà je crois
que nous sommes en mesure maintenant de
retrouver claude sérillon au centre
pompidou à beaubourg claude wearever je
suis toujours dans le grand hall du
centre georges pompidou la visite des
différentes personnalités qu'on ne doit
pas dire la république se poursuivront
donc dans l'exposition le visiteur et
son dos je suis pratiquement sous la
boule comment comment qualifier cela
c'est une sorte de statut de sculptures
mouvante de soto qui se trouve juste
derrière moi et qui est tout à fait
remarquable qui est tout à fait
impressionnant c'est dans le centre
pompidou nous sommes ici en directement
je crois que nous allons voir la météo
et puis ensuite je voudrais un tyran
dévouent pour ici à partir de la semaine
prochaine laurent bouvier oui absolument
pour une météo bien fraîche voilà une
météo bien fait on a toujours le centre
georges pompidou l'arrière une météo
bien fâché surtout une nuit très très
fraîche puisque cette nuit la nuit qui
arrivent les températures vont descendre
jusqu'à moins 9 degrés dans le centre
est moins 11 en région parisienne et -15
degrés dans l'est donc attention une
nuit très fraîche avec des risque de
gelée blanche très très fort cela dit la
journée de demain sera elle très
ensoleillée on vas tu te regarder la
photo satellite pelé cet après-midi par
meteosat toujours un anticyclone sur
l'europe s'est enquis grâce à cet
anticyclone et bien les nuages ne rentre
pas et pourtant ils aimeraient bien
arriver ils sont là sur l'atlantique sur
le golfe de gascogne et ils
s'approcheront demain petit à petit les
côtes de l'atlantique c'est là une carte
du temps prévu pour demain très
ensoleillé
avec quand même l'arrivée de quelques
nuages donc du très beau temps partout -
15 passes et les températures de la nuit
- lui ces températures de la nuit
la journée sera très ensoleillé mais je
vous le disais déjà quelques nuages qui
arrivent sur les côtes de l'atlantique
depuis quelques petits creux des nuages
résiduels dans le sud côté températures
elles restent fraîches avec des
températures encore inférieures à zéro
degré sur toute une moitié est et nord
est du pays - 5 à mulhouse ou moins 4 à
strasbourg 0 à paris seulement et puis
+4 dans le nord-ouest sur la moitié sud
0 degré encore à lyon et grenoble
quelques températures assez désagréable
10° 10 12 degrés sur la méditerranée 10
12 degrés également encore tout ça ça
descend quand même un tout petit peu oui
et on finit d'abord avec l'agenda
demain sera le premier jour de février
1er février et 1er février le soleil se
lèvera à 8h23 se couchera à 17h46 trois
minutes de soleil en plus nous fêterons
les ailes là et puis comme on allait
oublier donner les résultats du tiercé
voici les résultats du tiercé en rôle
tout à fait nouveau pour moi il fallait
jouer le 12 le 9 et le set je répète 12
le 9 et le 7eme voilà alors on vous
aurait tout fait dans votre carrière de
journaliste même le tiercé
je vous retrouve ici au centre georges
pompidou pour vous signaler qu'à partir
de lundi lundi 2 février à partir de 14
heures jusqu'à jusqu'à la nuit quoi
jusqu'à minuit à peu près mais ce sera
ouvert au public avec des séries de
concerts de jazz
vous êtes tous conviés à venir donc ici
c'est gratuit c'est tout versé pour les
10 ans du centre georges pompidou ce
soir dernier journal vous sera assuré à
nouveau parler avec l'autre je vous
retrouve demain à 20 heures et nous
aurons comme invité monsieur edouard
balladur à demain 20h bonsoir merci
le
un mort deux blessés graves c'est le
bilan d'un hold up sanglant à champigny
sur marne dans un centre commercial
les dix ans du centre pompidou
côte-à-côte jacques chirac françois
mitterrand et madame claude pompidou
c'était sur antenne 2 la convention de
l'udf les centristes définissent une
stratégie mais ne choisissent pas de
candidat pour les présidentielles
yves allégret est mort à l'âge de 79 ans
il était l'un des grands cinéastes de
l'après guerre nous sommes le 31 janvier
déjà le 1er février d'ailleurs puisque
nous minuit passé
les diplomates marcel fontaine marcel
carton le journaliste jean paul
kauffmann et notre camarade jean louis
normandin sont toujours otages au liban
bonsoir la violence quotidienne la
violence qui tourne mal à champigny sur
marne dans un centre commercial des
gangsters ont voulu s'emparer de la
recette la faire je vous le disais a mal
tourné
bilan un convoyeur de fonds tué une
jeune fille qui luttent entre la vie et
la mort et cinq autres blessées plus
légèrement
reportage christophe martet 18h30 samedi
soir à champigny sur marne deux
convoyeurs de fonds venant prendre
livraison de la recette du magasin
leclerc avance vers les caisses la trois
malfaiteurs armés les attendent
l'un d'eux une arme cachée dans un
bouquet de fleurs s'approche voyant
vraisemblablement larmes
un convoyeur fait feu et tirs 5 fois
contre le malfaiteur
la riposte de ses deux complices est
immédiate dans la fusillade une fillette
de 14 ans s'effondre très gravement
blessée à la tête
le convoyeur est tué quatre autres
personnes sont légèrement atteintes
rester à l'extérieur du magasin le
conducteur du fourgon raconte la
première chose que j'ai vue
puisque je suis tenu de surveiller
permet l'entrée du magasin c'est toute
cette foule
qui partait en criant tout de suite j'ai
entendu les coups de feu enfin tout ça
ça a été très rapide
dans le même temps j'ai vu mon collègue
aussi qui sait de ce débat parce qu'il
en avait un qui était approché avant lui
enfin il beaucoup de coups de feu oui
quand même oui
non non moi j'ai riposté de mon côté
après on a essayé de se tenir à l'abri
parce qu'ils ont plus tiré sous le
camion 1 et on n'a pas tenté quoi que ce
soit immédiatement après la fusillade
les trois malfaiteurs dont un grièvement
blessés ont pris la fuite à bord d'une
r5 blanche
de très nombreux effectifs de police ont
été mobilisés pour rétablir des
contrôles sur les routes du département
du val de marne à marseille l'explosion
d'une voiture piégée ce n'était pas un
attentat deux gangsters manipuler un
engin explosif de 4 à 5 kg dans leur
voiture ils s'apprêtaient sans doute à
faire un mauvais coup la charge leur a
explosé à la figure ils ont été tués
tous les deux quand l'art se visite en
cohabitation ce soir au centre pompidou
pour le dixième anniversaire trois
visiteurs de marque le président
mitterrand le premier ministre jacques
chirac et madame claude pompidou côte à
côte ils ont célébré dit vente succès il
faut dire que le centre pompidou et
maintenant avec plus de 7 millions de
visiteurs par an le monument français le
plus visité notre journal de 20h été
réalisée en direct de la ba jean-michel
mercurol pour les 10 ans du centre
pompidou aux côtés de françois
mitterrand un enfant qui aura 20 ans
l'an 2000 ensemble ils ont déclenché
l'horloge qui va égrener les secondes
jusqu'au deuxième millénaire
ici dans le décor futuriste du centre
beaubourg françois mitterrand qui avait
lui même défendu le projet comme il nous
l'a confié dans le journal de 20h j'ai
créé à l'époque des articles polémiques
or estimé qu'on commette une erreur en
refusant ce bâtiment audacieux dans ce
quartier
inscrit dans notre histoire est que
cette sorte d'anti nomi pouvait être
profitable à l'esthétique de la ville
l'homme ton pidoux je crois que votre
mari de président pompidou avait dit ça
va faire crier win avait dit ça va faire
crier et ça s'écrit et d'ailleurs ça
fait beaucoup qu'il y est est ce que
maintenant vous juger ça un petit peu
avec le sourire ou est ce que vous
retenez quand chose qu'on était un peu
dur non je retiens plus rien parce que
comme c'est un succès qui attendent
personnes qui viennent là tous les jours
puisque c'est la réalisation de son rêve
de ce qu'il avait pensé alors par
conséquent si où aucun regret non c'est
vrai que j'ai été dès le début associés
à cette grande aventure qu'en 1974 après
son décès hélas j'ai fait partie j'étais
premier ministre de ce qui contre vents
et marées et contre les cris que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure ils ont des
nombreux et les sarcasmes ont imposé la
réalisation du projet qu'il avait voulu
et qui sont évidemment la fois ému aussi
heureux de voir le grand succès qui est
universellement reconnue aujourd'hui à
l'égard du sein le président de la
république et le premier ministre après
avoir visité deux expositions l'une sur
l'architecturé du beaubourg l'autre sur
ses visiteurs ont assisté à un spectacle
de musique et des ballets contemporains
pour poursuivre les festivités de ce
dixième anniversaire le centre pompidou
ouvrira ses portes demain à partir de
midi pour 12 heures d'animations
gratuites